auditions were obviously a very
important part of the show do you have
any that stick out I do but you go first
do you have any auditions to stick out
there were just fun where do we begin
there was the great ones and the funny
ones what was the guy that was a lion
you thought he was a lions well because
that was real to reality because no one
had seen the show before so we saw and
heard some of the worst singers in
America they just kept throwing them on
to show it so we're sitting there going
what the hell is I will say this I went
right after the girl that sang Lady
Marmalade and like opera for like oh I
think I have this well I think that's
what we said at the end of the auditions
shows what the hell just happened I said
okay I thought this is gonna be such a
disaster I didn't even know I went back
to England I didn't even know the show
was on and I got this phone call from
this producer who was screaming down the
phone's thing you know you've got it hit
and I said what the show aired last
night I went really and say hey I went
watch I really thought it would last
about two weeks and we get yeah we had
the best have any criticism that you
regret or just things that happen in
your like maybe I didn't hear it right
or I wish we never used the word
blancmange
we give each other a word you have the
name game and it was during a live show
and Simon we it's like what's so excited
about and I will say it was damn fine
what's the name done name game he did
this we would write down the piece of
paper see whatever happens you have to
use this he goes Randy Paula here's my
black card ten minutes on Rodeo Drive if
you incorporate these words into your
critique no Randy is an English dessert
no you gave Randy spotted dick
[Applause]
explain to Kelly what that is well it is
it is an old-fashioned England English's
if you go on Google please Google
spotted dick then delete your Google
search history and then when we did life
and we're under pressure Paula would
sudden I say to me give me something to
say when people leave so I would make up
poorly is so boring steers have nothing
to say interesting you're so boring say
the moths that defines a melon ball
inside of a one time Paula and I'm
crying laughing and I go he said the
mother finds a melon oh my god you
cheater up but we've got fun driving fun
because you're fun doing it which all
ever work together again a hundred
percent
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he is so good Adam Lambert Oh blew you
away from day one I was sneaky I know
everybody didn't kinda remember me for a
minute like who was hubli away from day
one cuz for me it was I was blown away
with honestly to my orange eye on my
season tomorrow Justin but then you came
in you were so raw and honest with no
pretense that I was like Yoshi's fire
right there
I remember thinking what just happened
oh yeah you knew who you were as an
artist you picked the right songs and
I'll never forget the biggest treat is I
was writing in the elevator it CBS with
you and you were vocalizing it and you
were singing opera and I was like
started is there anything this girl
can't do such a natural you were just
like you had that whole soulful vibe he
was just natural with it what think I
actually agree with that with like the
whole season our first season it was so
new none of us knew we weren't entitled
because everybody was just trying to pay
their electric bill people like nobody
we didn't think it was gonna go anywhere
and so you know we were kids at camp and
it was something so cool about that
first season I will say though I'm very
working that season I will never do
something as hard they worked us so hard
like we were doing so many things and
everybody like they're like oh your
schedules so busy now and I'm like
whatever in the movie I've gotta turn
the moon better standing ovations
I would have you saw please please
please my nanny should be fired if she
should I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this